foreign
uh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
good afternoon
[Applause]
earlier this semester
i went to grab a cup of coffee in a
dining hall
it was a sunny day early in the morning
and the world felt quiet
i decided to take the long way home
lingering in the silence of campus for a
few extra moments
i walked and i thought about all the
people still asleep who surrounded me
warm in their beds not yet conscious of
the day
on rosewalk a woman wheeling a cart of
papers walks swiftly by phone in hand
i overheard a snippet of a conversation
she was having in french
at elm she turned right and disappeared
i stopped and i thought about her
we had just shared a moment though
perhaps she was unaware of it and i was
struck by how much i could guess about
her life
i could guess that she was probably
calling someone she cared about very
much that she likely had experienced
homesickness as all people do who live
far from home that it took planning and
care to call someone who is ending their
day as she began hers that it wasn't
always easy
i realized we had a lot in common
despite me not knowing her and her not
knowing me
i spent a lot of time in college missing
phone calls from friends and family when
it's morning here everyone i love back
home is asleep
like this woman i've experienced
homesickness i've learned how much
effort it takes to maintain
relationships with people who live far
away and also how much this effort is
always worth it
at yale we are connected to a certain
extent by virtue of being at this school
if you are pre-med i know you probably
had a hard semester in orgo perhaps your
hard semester in orgo coincided with my
hard semester in american lit
perhaps we cried at the same time in the
same library me one floor above
we are connected because we can guess
just enough about each other's lives
because we share yale
but the same still holds true without
needing to share yale
in fact what i had in common with the
woman on rose walk had little to do with
yale it had much more to do with
choosing to notice what connected us
many of us are about to enter a world of
strangers a world of unfamiliar people
faces and names and we're terrified of
this
we have an idea that yale is the end of
all possibility for human connection
the end of friendship
an idea that is distinctly anti-stranger
and an idea that does nothing for us but
close us off from the world
but yale has prepared us for life beyond
college by equipping us with one
especially important skill
perception
while we use this skill all the time in
our learning we also use it every time
we meet a new person we have learned to
connect with people from all kinds of
backgrounds all kinds of places
and though we may tell ourselves that we
are friends because we share yale the
truth is that while yale may have
brought us together this school has
never been the reason for our connection
yale has given you a perceptive eye
use it with intention
notice the girl wearing a t-shirt with
your favorite band on it listen to the
languages and accents that surround you
peer over the shoulder of the person
sitting next to you on the subway
maybe they're reading your favorite book
getting lost in something that brought
you joy back when you were sitting in a
classroom in lc
and on the days when you don't want to
be perceptive that's okay too
pick up the phone and call the people
who are sitting next to you today
remember that connection exists in many
forms in many moments
through being perceptive you will
discover friendship empathy and
community
in other words you will bring the
feeling of yale with you into all of the
spaces you inhabit
congratulations class of 2022 and good
luck out there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
hello hello
assalamu alaikum and welcome friends
family loved ones but most importantly
the yale class of 2022 to class day
my name is yusra omer and i'm one of the
five members of the class day committee
as a member of this committee i have had
the pleasure of working with yale
faculty staff and fellow students to
bring you this celebration to
commemorate commemorate our yale
experience as a class
god j5
good afternoon everyone my name is jay
pfeiffer and i'm also a member of the
yale class of 2022 class day committee
class day emerged in the 19th century as
yellies gathered here on old campus to
recount share and create memories
on this beautiful day we will celebrate
the historic yale class of 2022 with
reflections witness members of our class
receive prizes for academic artistic and
athletic achievements and practice
long-standing class day traditions
later in the ceremony our three fellow
committee members will share more
details about those traditions but first
up is the class day address delivered
each year by a notable speaker
returning to yale for our keynote
address res mashodani comes to share her
journey and the wisdom collected along
the way with the class of 2022 but she
also comes to be inspired by the
resilience bravery and determination of
our graduating class
mr johnny's life is driven by
inspiration as a first generation
immigrant coming from a family of indian
refugees to uganda she grew up in
illinois and attended the university of
illinois earning her bachelor's degree
in our shared field of political science
as with any of our journeys all roads
lead back to yale but mr johnny decided
to take a trip to a lesser-known
institution
the harvard kennedy school of business
the government oh shoot already messing
around up
no one's familiar with that one so
she went there to earn her master's in
public policy and then arrived at the
golden gates of the yale law school
where she received her juris doctorate
in 2002.
mr johnny has had an illustrious career
from her work as an attorney political
organizer campaigning for a seat in the
u.s house of representatives serving as
the new york city deputy public advocate
and founding girls who code a non-profit
striving to close the gender gap by
teaching girls and young women computing
skills so they can be more competitive
within the technology sector
mr johnny has been recognized among
fortune world's greatest leaders
fortune's 40 under 40 list and as one of
forbes most powerful women changing the
world among others
but perhaps some of her greatest
accomplishments come in the form of her
family with her husband the heel and
their sons sean and cy
her career speaks for itself and
embodies several of the fields that many
of us will be entering in the not so
distant future
to
find out how she does it all there is
only one way to do it and it's to hear
from mr johnny herself so without
further ado please join me in welcoming
back to yale mr smith johnny
[Applause]
all right i just have to say it damn
it's hot
uh
it is an honor to be here um i want to
thank president salovey the dean's
distinguished guest the graduates
and i also want to give a special shout
out to
our parents
and our family
i am honored to be here today with my
husband nahal and my son sean and sai
my father my sister kashma and my niece
maya
the truth is is especially after the
past two years
none of us get to this stage alone
there's been a lot of sacrifice
a lot of commitment
a lot of love
in our journey to get to this stage and
so i want to recognize all of the
parents and family who got us here and
friends thank you
before i get started
i wanted to get out the elephant in the
room
i'm sure some of you are were a little
disappointed when you found out that i
was going to be your class day speaker
maybe you even thought who's that
and googled me on the way over here
and i get it i get it you've had some
pretty amazing class day speakers you've
had your fair share of presidents
including biden
and clinton
and of course how can we forget bill
clinton
uh
but
today you get something even more
powerful than a president
you get a pissed off mom living in
america so congratulations
[Applause]
so
a lot has changed
in the 20 years since i graduated
from this incredible
university
but i suspect
not much has changed
about the kind of students
that come to yale
i know this may come as a shock to you
but i too
was an insufferable overachiever
i graduated college in three years as
valedictorian
and i set out to attend the best law
school in the country
in 1989 i had gotten my hands on a copy
of a u.s news and world report
and there it was
right at the top
yale
i took that page and i tacked it to my
bedroom wall in middle school
like i said
insufferable
i applied to yale not once
not twice but three separate times i
only got close when i pleaded my case to
the dean of admissions at a funeral
so classy right
the dean made me a deal
he said
get into any law school in the country
and i'll let you transfer to yale
so i grinded
and i grinded
and i got to the top of my class at
georgetown law
only after all of that
did yale finally let me in
big mistake on their part
my campaign to get into yale was the
first of many for me
i ran for office twice
i started an organization to teach girls
to code
and most recently
i've built a movement
to support mothers and working women
through the pandemic
[Applause]
i love advocacy
i love fighting for people
especially women and girls
and i love that change is possible
here
that pushing and agitating for things to
be different
is a big part of what it means to live
in america
to form the more perfect union right
or how about this one
maybe the most famous line said
by a u.s president
say it with me
ask not what your country
can do for you
but what you can do for your country
so iconic
so catchy
so deeply woven into america america's
consciousness
that it doesn't matter whether you're
from here
or from another nation
you probably know those words by heart
but can i tell you something
lately
when i hear jfk's famous words
it makes me
kind of angry
because i can't help but place those
words
in their historical context
and compare them to the times we're
living through today
and hear them
just a little bit
differently
let's rewind the tape
it's january 1961
kennedy's inauguration
america is feeling the aftershocks of a
generation defining crisis there's
tension abroad in russia and china
and there's tension back here at home
too around racial quality and the right
to vote
sound familiar
the big difference though between back
then and now is back then america was
getting the job done
think about that era
post world war ii
the united states was literally creating
a whole new world order
with institutions like the un nato the
world bank the imf
we were sprinting to win the space race
and creating life-saving vaccines
against polio and measles back when we
were into that kind of thing
we were increasing social security
raising the minimum wage creating food
stamps developing the interstate highway
passing the civil rights act i mean the
list goes on and on
and on
america
was doing a lot
not enough
not for everyone
but it was doing
a lot
so it's no wonder
that in the early 60s
when pew asked the american people
do you trust the federal government to
do what's right
75
of americans said yes
amazing
75
so in that context when jfk takes the
stage and he addresses the american
people for the first time as their u.s
president and he asked them to stand up
for their country it resonates
it reverberates for decades it still
reverberates it's quoted constantly i
just did a minute ago but the question
is
does it
resonate
last year pew asked the american people
the same question do you trust the
federal government to do what's right
this time
only 22
of americans said yes
now
i've run for office
i've served in government i am the first
generation daughter
of political refugees
this country
literally saved my parents life
i'm the definition
of the american dream
so believe me
i want to be in that 22 percent
i do
but i'm also a working mom
living in the only industrialized nation
that doesn't offer paid leave let alone
flexibility
and your students
graduating with billions of dollars of
student loan debt
something that the government can do
something about but won't
this
is a community
new haven
where half the population lost their
jobs in covid
and many still can't pay the rent
in a country in an in a state that has
the largest
income inequality
in the country
in a nation
where millions
are suffering
from mental illness
drowning under medical debt
in a nation
that rather force birth
and sometimes even force
death
then give us autonomy over our own
bodies
[Applause]
in a world
with racial injustice violent
authoritarianism and a climate crisis
that is getting worse by the second
all of this
was before
a once in a century pandemic that the
government repeatedly
refused to manage effectively
so
ask us
what we
can do for our country
are you
kidding me
your generation
has marched for black lives labor rights
climate rights you've challenged the
stigma around mental illness you've held
powerful institutions accountable
including your very
own
university
[Applause]
class of 2022
jfk's words
were not
for you
instead
he would want you
to ask your country
what your country can do for you
because i bet a degree
it should be doing a hell of a lot more
it should be providing health care and
child care saving our planet and our
democracy making the rich pay their fair
share and yes making workplaces pay
up
so yes
[Applause]
ask your representatives
state
local and yes even your president
democrat republican or whatever ticket
eli sabin runs on in the next four years
[Applause]
ask them
ask them
to tear down these broken structures and
build up equitable ones and ask your
partners your community
and your workplaces to do the same
and i know you will
but here's the catch
don't do it
now you're not ready
don't get me wrong
i know
that this is a generation a class
of leaders
eager to use the gift and the privilege
of your education
to go out in the world with
open-mindedness
courage and contemplation
but before you can ask your country what
your country can do for you
you have to ask
what you
can do for yourself
let me explain
you know i told you about the story how
i got here
applied to yale three times top of my
class at georgetown blah blah blah
well here's the rest of the story
my time at georgetown was
miserable
i was so
focused on getting into yale
that i didn't do basic things
like sleep eight hours a day
eat three meals
make a single friend
and so by the time i got to yale
i was exhausted
so i did the best thing i have ever
done for myself
i just stopped
and i went
oh i like you
and i went from having no friends
literally no friends in dc
to having a group of inseparable
girlfriends
here in new haven
the 10 of us were some of the only women
of color
at yale law
and back at home we were shining
examples of perfection
but because we had given up so much
to get to this institution
when we got here
we had nothing left to give
so instead
we partied every thursday night at gypsy
we danced to j.lo missy elliott and
britney spears
we skipped class and went to watch sex
in the city in sopranos
and for the first time in my life
i cared more about investing in myself
in my relationships
than investing in my career
and it felt incredible
now
because i chose that path
i didn't fulfill a lot of yale law
rights of passage
i wasn't editor of my law review
i didn't get a clerkship
in fact
i asked a professor to write a
recommendation letter for me
and while he wrote me a letter
he recommended not hiring me
i think he still works here anyway back
to my commencement speech
so
you would have thought that i learned my
lesson
that i would have left yale
with my battery recharged
ready to go change the world
well i left gail and i went to go work
at a white shoe law firm
where i got fired
because my heart was so not into it
you would have thought after that
that i'd be ready to go fight the good
fight
well fight i did with my bosses at my
new soulless hedge fund job
why to keep doing that
why did i keep doing that why did i keep
falling
into this hustle
culture
trap
but back then
i didn't think i had a choice
i had spent my whole life
studying
on how to be a girl boss
how to have it all
and look good doing it
that i thought my degree at yale would
just unlock a lifetime of more
more titles and promotions more
accolades and magazine profiles
thankfully that aspiration is no longer
in fashion
and i'm pretty sure y'all would rather
wear a harvard t-shirt right now than a
girl boss one
but that sentiment
that you should be ambitious but likable
relentless
but effortless
still lives on
and when we can't balance having it all
we think that's a personal failure
rather than a structural one
for so long
i was so ashamed
of my time here at yale
i thought i should have done more
tried harder
but i'm so grateful for my time
exactly
as it was
because it taught me
that when i take care of myself
i can better take care of others
and fight for them too
it taught me to be a better leader a
better advocate a better wife a better
mother a better neighbor a better friend
all i ever wanted
was this degree
but i'm far more grateful
for the lesson
to be sure
self-care has been co-opted beyond
recognition
by billion-dollar corporations that are
telling you to practice self-care
and then work 80 hours a week
they want you to fix
what they've broken
that's not self-care that's corporate
strategy
[Applause]
class of 2022
you don't need fixing
you won't
need fixing
but after the past two years
you will
need healing
we all will
healing is doing whatever your body your
soul your mind your spirit needs to
recharge
it's re-examining your relationships
with yourself your community your world
your nation your faith
you know outside of my hindu temple in
queens
there's a statue of a turtle
and the turtle is there to remind you
that sometimes you're at your strongest
when you withdraw
that you gotta go inward first
before charging
forward
graduates
go inward
heal yourself
only then can you heal the nation
because yes yes yes
your country needs you
just not in the way jfk imagined
your country needs you to take care of
each other
and reimagine a world that better takes
care of us
your country needs you to break that
hustle culture trap
and build
new workplaces stronger communities new
social programs systems
that support our mental health
rather than tear it down
our country needs you to
fight for rights
rights
shockingly we can't take for granted
in 2022
the right to choose what you choose love
who you love be
who you are
because we know that our struggles are
intertwined
and so is our path to freedom
our country needs you to be braver
than i was when i left this place
i wish
i had your wisdom
to advocate for my mental health
to set boundaries
to fight for my rights at home
and at work
i wish i had your perspective
to know what truly matters
to know which fights were energizing me
and which ones were exploiting me
i wish i had permission
permission to be selfish
and not selfish in the egomaniacal or
cynical sense
but selfish in the purest sense of the
word
to take care of myself
so i could better go out in the world
and do the work
in the words of the brilliant audra lord
caring for myself
is not self-indulgence
it's self-preservation
and that is an act of political warfare
[Applause]
class of 2022
this is my gift to you
i give you permission
to be selfish
to ask more from others
especially those
who have more to give
to build systems
around care
rather than capital
[Music]
to tend to your own brilliant flame
before sharing your light
with the rest of us
i trust
i know
that you will use this gift wisely
thank you and congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you miss alejani for those
very inspiring words for reminding us to
care for each other and through your own
example showing how we can do so
i really appreciate your authenticity
and power
and you know i've been through a lot of
these events you are certainly one of
our best speakers so thank you again
[Applause]
um all right seniors um i have some
business uh that i need to conduct with
you but first i want to ask the
following students to come up to the
seats in the front row
chia amisola of sabre college
kaylee delay of morris college
jalen king of benjamin franklin college
matthew john king of ezra styles college
gabriel louis claphols of brantford
college
e.c mingo of ezra stiles college
mary elizabeth orsack of pearson college
azar swain of timothy dwight college
alex winnington of pearson college
sarah ming xin zhao of berkeley college
[Applause]
as they get settled
for all of you
we have to do a little dress rehearsal
for tomorrow for the university
commencement back here in this space
there's going to be a point when i stand
up here in front of president salivay
and present you to him so that you can
receive your degrees
so listen up
the last two sentences of my request to
president salovey
are going to be
they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college and approved by
the corporation
i now ask you by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees
when you hear these words
confer upon them these degrees
i want to hear you loud and clear okay
you're graduating
so let's practice
they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college and approved by
the corporation
i now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry you're muted
let's try again
have been recommended by the faculty of
yale college and approved by the
corporation i now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
better than
well kaylee delay and azar swain please
come up to the stage
i am thrilled to announce that the
nellie p elliott and william neely
mallory awards for the senior woman and
man whose excellence in the field of
athletics and in their life at yale best
represent the highest ideals of
sportsmanship and yale tradition go this
year to the two walking up here kaylie
delay and azar swain
kaylie
through hard work and determination she
molded herself into one of the top
distant runners in the nation
she is an nca cross-country all-american
she won an incredible 10th place
nationally in cross country
she won back-to-back ivy league
championships in cross country in 2019
and 2021
she was the ivy league champion in the
3000 meters in 2020 and 2022.
she holds the yell record in 3 000
meters 5 000 meters indoors five
thousand meters outdoors and three
thousand meters in the steeplechase
she holds the number two all-time mark
in the ivy league in both the
steeplechase and the 5 000 meter indoors
she was a 2020 olympic trials qualifier
qualifier in the 3 000 meter steeple
chase
she did all of this while holding down
an environmental engineering major
researching at the school of public
health
and being an onexis student coach
for representing tremendous athletic
account accomplishment on the field and
for being everything that a yale student
athlete should be
on and off the field yell takes pride in
awarding the nellie p elliott award to
kaylee delay
azar
he is one of the all-time great yale
basketball players
he helped lead his team through an
incredible season
in which the bulldogs won 19 games and
captured the ivy league tournament title
with a thrilling victory over princeton
and earned an ncaa tournament bid for
the third straight time
he played in more games in yale history
than any other yale basketball player
ever that's a 121 games to be exact
he was part of four championships two
regular season and two tournament titles
he averaged 19.2 points per game his
senior year
he has a remarkable record of
271 career threes which is first
all-time at yale
he was ivy league tournament mvp in 2022
with
1529 career points and he was a finalist
for lou henson award for best mid-major
player in the country
like kaylee he took a year off during
covid in order to return to help his
team have the best possible chance to
repeat as ivy league champions he earned
tremendous respect from opposing coaches
and players alike due to his competitive
nature and talents on the court and his
excellent sportsmanship
and he was in addition a fan favorite
someone who garnered the respect and
admiration of all bulldog fans
for his tremendous athletic
accomplishment his relentlessly hard
work and his stature as a competitor of
great integrity and honor yale takes
great pride in awarding the william
neely mallory award to azar swain
[Applause]
here you go
[Applause]
jalen king and e.c mingo please come up
to the stage
the nakanishi prize is awarded to two
graduating seniors who while maintaining
high academic achievement have provided
exemplary leadership in enhancing race
or ethnic relations at yale college this
year's prizes are awarded to jalen king
of benjamin franklin college and e.c
mingo of ezra styles college
[Applause]
jalen king a molecular cellular and
developmental biology major is an
advocate for social justice and
community both at yale and in new haven
jalen has been an active member of the
black student alliance at yale black
public health professionals at yale and
black students for disarmament at yale
he has also been the primary coordinator
of coalition building efforts among
cultural centers across campus together
with organizations in new haven
through his work he has amplified the
voices of black women on campus and in
new haven centered the experiences of
black new haven in relation to yale and
advocated for residents respectful
treatment and well-being
jalen is also a proud member of the ada
alpha lambda chapter of alpha phi alpha
inc and was integral to the black men's
union from his very steps onto campus he
developed a co-curriculum to educate bmu
students about masculinity and
racialized gender issues instituting
webinars mentoring and a book club to
educate his organization and hold peers
accountable for their actions their
learning and future advocacy on behalf
of the black community at large for his
extraordinary service and leadership
yale college is honored to award the
nakanishi prize to jalen king
evan craig mingo graduates with
distinction in both his majors
ethnicity race and migration and
psychology
within and beyond his academic work ec
has given voice labor and leadership to
the difficult often unseen work of
social justice
ec has created workshops on
anti-blackness in indigenous communities
to support afro-indigenous students at
the native american cultural center he
has worked on diversity equity and
inclusion initiatives for both the
community and consent educators program
and the department of psychology
ec was selected as one of the inaugural
cohort of the coalition of allyship
advocates to develop approaches to
enhancing race and ethnic relations on
campus and he also established the
student organization blackout
to provide a space
where black
lgbtqia plus peers could engage with the
implications of this specific
intersection of identity
in all his roles on campus ec has raised
questions and addressed the problems of
discrimination colorism transphobia
homophobia classism and other inequities
that might otherwise go unaddressed his
aim is always to generate critical
conversations plan productive strategy
and reconcile his peers
for his extraordinary service and
leadership yale college is honored to
award the nakanishi prize to evan craig
mingo
[Applause]
the james andrew haas prize is awarded
annually to quote that member of the
senior class in yale college whose
breadth of intellectual achievement
strength of character and fundamental
humanity shall be adjudged by the
faculty
to have provided leadership for his or
her fellow students inspiring in them a
love of learning and concern for others
this year the haas prize is awarded to
arya sang of pauly murray college
arya
[Applause]
arya sang graduates summa [ __ ] laude with
distinction in her major history of
science medicine and public health
and as an education studies scholar
she received last fall the francis
gordon prize brown prize for her
intellectual ability high personhood
capacity for leadership and service to
the university arya has always promoted
accessibility and equity in health care
systems asking how to humanize medicine
and leave fewer patients falling through
the cracks
she has inspired peers mentors and
colleagues through her work with chapel
haven's asperger syndrome adult
transition program with focus and defy
disability empowerment for yale
as president of the yale undergraduate
legal aid association she expanded the
organization's reach partnering with the
connecticut veterans legal clinic
she also serves on the new haven
commission on disabilities to which she
was appointed by new haven's mayor and
her 2020 children's book courageous cala
and the clinical trial offers children
and their families a better way to
understand informed consent for research
studies
next year she will finish her master's
in public health at the yale school of
public health
[Music]
for her outstanding achievements her
leadership and service and for her
commitment to accessibility equity and
inclusivity yale college is proud to
bestow the james andrew haas memorial
prize upon arya channing thang
[Music]
[Applause]
yale university
what's the good word
[Music]
wait
what what what are you guys doing here
um
we're giving the comedic reflection we
the last four years were so brutal and
we have a lot of jokes to make uh what
do you mean the last four years were
entirely awesome yeah and we have so
many fun memories to joke about
okay first of all no
no one said that since bulldog days
and second of all do you see how tired
our classmates look
no that's just how they look without
their masks
can i just say class of 2022 i think you
all look great in your hats and gowns
but only the originals 20 21 plus ones
why are you still here
[Applause]
you look old get a job
okay
we don't want to bore you with any
reminders of this terrible pandemic so
let's just get all the covert stuff out
of the way
unprecedented
[Laughter]
[Applause]
feels good to get that out of our system
you know i kind of liked the pandemic
you did
yeah uh i followed yale's example and i
bought zoom stock early on
and you know
i didn't mind mask wearing either
when my friends didn't laugh at my jokes
i could just assume they were silent
smilers and i couldn't see it
okay but also a lot of things during our
time at yale suck that had nothing to do
with the pandemic yeah like first year
formal
chase we went to first year formal
together
yeah
guys first year wasn't all that bad
yeah remember our first year
matriculation ceremony when that rabbit
duck image was displayed for what we can
only imagine was the 30th year in a row
yeah it was supposed to teach us about
perspective but uh
well it was really just inspirational to
me as an english major because it showed
i can uh
reuse material and
just hope people forget
[Applause]
okay well what about that time when
people organized against universal pass
and we got to hear the worst takes at
yale since i was deferred when i applied
early action
[Applause]
yeah it's been four years you've got to
get over that you know ehi i'm with you
i got deferred too they gave my spot to
some olympic figure skater i don't know
but uh when i got here i fought off that
old inferiority complex by joining 30
clubs nine majors and taking 18 classes
when did you sleep in those 18 classes
to be fair my professors had very
soothing voices
also ehi why are you so pessimistic
about yale when it's the place that
cultivated our talents
do you know how good i've gotten at
borrowing things
borrowing mugs from the pearson dining
hall
borrowing sushi from from the bow wow
borrowing portraits from the yale center
for british art
makrino what was that last one there no
marine i guess you're right
you know i actually started making art
at yale oh yeah i didn't know you did
art yeah i'm like the jackson pollock of
street art my canvas unsuspecting yale
he's out to get a late night jihab
sandwich
are you the paintballer
no
[Laughter]
yale also broadened my world view
where else do you get to learn about
china's geopolitical role in the world
and afrofuturism
all from different white men
[Applause]
exactly
but now we just wanted to take a moment
to remember all of the things that we've
lost
durfees
the taco bell cantina
[Applause]
those evangelicals that used to be all
over campus
[Applause]
that flagpole that was on cross campus
for three weeks
jojo's
my cultural house
your cultural house
you know
siguep now eden
[Applause]
oh word word
i get it you guys you know so much has
changed during our time at yale
coming back to campus this year felt
like what i imagined the class of 1968
feels when they returned for reunions
like whoa
women
yeah it's crazy like one second where
sophomores and the next were seniors
yeah who are these kids i have to
babysit
yeah who are these kids i have to
babysit
guys you're froco's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is literally your job
anyways
now we would like to shout out some
special people who showed up for us
today
thank you to all our haters
you know who you are and we wouldn't be
here without you
can we also acknowledge our incredible
class day speaker miss reshma sojani the
founder of girls who code
uh
i would just like to pitch you my own
non-profit miss and johnny uh just
spitballing here i don't know if you
want to multiply your numbers maybe but
how would you feel about boys who code
no that is literally the opposite of
what we need
kyle that is the yale computer science
department
[Applause]
all right all right all right fine fine
here is one more
never-before-used original thought to
send you all home with where are you
going with this kyle my stomach is
crumbling
uh
there's this uh this thing that looks
like a rabbit and it sometimes also
looks like a duck
where are you going with this now kyle
my stomach's rumbling
oh i get it yeah you look at this place
from one angle it's an ugly duckling our
trying times are late nights crying in
the basement of bingham
but if you look at it from another it's
our lucky rabbit's foot a place where
we've had incredible opportunities to
make memories and friends we can call on
long after those crying nights in the
basement of bingham
guys did we just learn perspective
all i learned is the next time i see a
familiar looking south asian woman
passing my residential college but i
don't want to say anything because i
don't want to seem racist i'm going to
regret it because that is definitely
mindy kaling
right well
there's still so much more i want to say
about this place
[Music]
why don't we sum it up all right
well complicated
bright college years
bye bye marvin john
handsome dan
what are you doing this weekend your mom
why do we stay for laundry
never stop complaining
thank you
[Applause]
that was great um i was getting
you know you know i was getting tired of
the duck rabbit at demo two so
[Applause]
gabriel claphols will you please come up
to the stage
[Music]
the arthur twining hadley prize which
honors the memory of the man who served
as president of yale from 1899 to 1921
is awarded annually to the senior in
yale college majoring in the social
sciences who ranks highest in
scholarship this year the prize is
awarded to gabriel klapholz of brantford
college
[Applause]
[Music]
gabriel klapholz graduates summa [ __ ]
laude with majors in history and global
affairs and with distinction in both of
his majors he has also completed the
multi-disciplinary academic program in
human rights studies as a first-year
student he was awarded the e francis
riggs memorial prize for distinction in
directed studies he was elected to phi
beta kappa in his first in the first
election in the fall of his junior year
and he is a 2022 recipient of a fox
international fellowship
beyond the classroom gabriel's impact on
campus has been widely felt from his
work as opinion editor for the yield
daily news as a staff writer for the
yell politic to his service as the
co-president of the yale undergraduate
legal aid association
an awardee of the lyman summer
fellowship from the yale law school and
an editorial intern at the yale law
journal gabriel has shown a dedication
to working for equity and justice that
will surely have an impact well beyond
yale as well
in recognition of his exceptional record
and promise of future success yale
college proudly confers the arthur
twining high scholarship prize this year
upon gabrielle claphols
[Applause]
matthew king and sarah zhao will you
please come up to the stage
the russell henry chittenden prize is
awarded annually for the senior majoring
in the natural sciences or in
mathematics who ranks highest in
scholarship this year's prize is awarded
jointly to matthew john king of ezra
cells college and sarah ming xin zhao of
berkeley college
matthew king
matthew king a double major in physics
intensive and mathematics intensive
graduates summa [ __ ] laude with
distinction in both majors in his junior
year he was elected to phi beta kappa
and sigma pi sigma
outside of the classroom matt devotes
much of his time to creative expression
and teaching others he has served as an
undergraduate learning assistant in the
mathematics department a course-based
peer tutor in the physics department and
an instructor with yell splash he is an
eagle scout the president of the yale
guild of bookmakers and an accomplished
writer and musician
an aspiring professor matt has spent the
last two summers researching particle
physics at the fermi lab in illinois he
will begin a phd in particle physics at
yale in the fall and has been awarded a
fellowship by the national science
foundation's graduate research
fellowship program
for his exceptional scholarship and his
future promise in his field yale college
is proud to confer the russell henry
chittenden prize upon matthew king
[Applause]
sarah zhao a double major in mathematics
and statistics and data science while
also completing a simultaneous master's
degree in statistics and data science
graduates summa [ __ ] laude and with
distinction in both majors inducted into
phi beta kappa in her junior year she is
a 2022 churchill scholar
and winner of the bishop barkley prize
given to the berkeley college senior who
has best discovered the intellectual
potentialities of a university she also
was named a barry m goldwater scholar in
2021
sarah has conducted research in a
variety of areas including theoretical
statistics diffusion geometry and
topology and quantum computing
beyond the classroom sarah has served as
a co-president of yale's phi beta kappa
chapter a board member of the yale
education tutoring initiative and an
undergraduate learning assistant for the
mathematics and statistics and data
science departments next year she will
use her churchill scholarship to pursue
an enfield degree in advanced computer
science with a focus on machine learning
at the university of cambridge
for her exceptional scholarship and her
future promise in her field yale college
is proud to confer the russell henry
chittenden prize upon sarah ming xin
zhao
wow
[Applause]
and alex whittington will you please
come up to the stage
the louis sudler prizes for excellence
in the performing and creative arts are
awarded to two outstanding seniors chia
amisola of sabre college and alex
whittington of pearson college
[Applause]
chia
a computing and arts major on the visual
art track graduates [ __ ] laude and with
distinction an artist who uses
technology to question and contemplate
the nature of the virtual world chia
makes work that treats digital space
like a tactile medium shaping it into
something at once foreign and familiar
and that requires audiences particularly
young ones to acknowledge their complex
relationships with their online lives
using computer applications games within
games and social worlds mapped on to
real geography
chio exposes the pervasive powerful
forces of the digital world both
positive and negative and how they have
become some of the most important most
deeply felt aspects of our lives
much of this work has already made an
impact around the world through chia's
non-profit
develop
for her exceptional talent and vision
present and future yale college is proud
to award the lewis sedler prize for
excellence in the creative and
performing arts to chia mai sola
[Applause]
alex whittington a music major
graduating [ __ ] laude and with
distinction is a multi-dimensional
performer whose work in the theater and
concert hall brings new perspectives to
works that cross cross cultural and
social boundaries
alex is a singer conductor director and
choreographer who breathes life into
music old and new drawing on their
experience in marginalized spaces of
puerto rican queer identity as well as a
solid grounding in received traditions
of music as art with a range that spans
greek tragedy to broadway alex has
created performances that are as
technologically accomplished as they are
artistically motivated drawing equally
on multi-disciplinary technical
expertise and personal journey and
demonstrating a serious belief in the
relevance and importance of the
performing arts in today's society
for their extraordinary artistic talents
and anticipation of their creative work
ahead yale college is proud to award the
lewis settler prize for excellence in
the performing arts to alex whittington
[Applause]
mary elizabeth orsack will you please
come up to the stage
[Applause]
the warren memorial high scholarship
prize is awarded to the senior majoring
in the humanities who ranks highest in
scholarship
the alpheus henry snow prize is awarded
to that senior who through the
combination of intellectual achievement
character and personality shall be a
judge by the faculty to have done the
most for yale by inspiring in his or her
classmates and admiration and love for
the best traditions of high scholarship
this year both the warren and the snow
prize are awarded to mary elizabeth
orsack of pearson college
[Applause]
mary elizabeth orsack graduates summa
[ __ ] laude with distinction in her major
russian
she was elected to phi beta kappa after
just four terms of enrollment
mary has served in three separate
research assistantships ranging widely
in form and focus from the archival
study of materials in the guggenheim
museum and the museum of modern art
collections
to the production of web content and
graphics on russian hackers to the
planning of a conference on the use of
bodies as a form of protest in russian
and eastern european performance art she
has also worked as a language tutor in
both russian and czech in the yale
center for language study as an art and
architectural editorial and marketing
intern for yale university press and as
a managing and design editor for the
yale review of international studies
mary has long served the community as a
volunteer both at the university and
across the city of new haven she was a
member of the advisory committee on
community policing and director at
walden peer counseling where she
provided anonymous non-directive peer
guidance to other students
she also served for two years as
curriculum director for community health
educators planning and offering classes
on health wellness and sexuality to
public school students in the city
she has also continued to be involved in
her hometown of dallas where she founded
and serves as president of a non-profit
story power inc
which is dedicated to promote to
improving the lives of young girls
through the donation of books about and
by inspiring women
next year mary will pursue a master of
philosophy in russian and east european
studies at oxford university as a rhodes
scholar
in in recognition of her intellectual
achievements and her exemplary character
as a community citizen yale college is
proud to award both the warren memorial
high scholarship prize and the alpheus
henry snow prize to marry elizabeth
orsack
[Applause]
[Music]
four years ago
i came to yale cautiously hopeful but
more candidly cynical
before yale i had attended a pre-college
summer program that i was initially
incredibly excited about
instead it turned out to be a complete
disaster
students asked to remove me from photos
because my wheelchair ruined it
asked the bus driver to leave without me
because the lift took too long and the
list goes on
perhaps unsurprisingly the experience
jaded me
it convinced me that contrary to what i
had hoped for
college would be a place where i would
be defined by my disability and that
that service level of understanding
would lead to perpetual exclusion
i was ready to repeat the summer of 2017
for four more years
yale powerfully and unexpectedly
restored the hope that i had lost by
consistently countering that narrative
through this community's unconditional
integrity and culture of acceptance
yale is a place where people can
meaningfully dream towards a future that
they create
for every person here
that means something uniquely beautiful
how did i become so convinced of this
that i'm sharing it with all of you
today
it is the living proof i have through
experiencing daily acts of compassion
that extend beyond what i find
comprehensible
to be humbling
hilarious and heartwarming
it is the place where when i'm perhaps
shamefully texting while driving in the
dining hall and subsequently drop a
plate
someone will be there to pick it up
it is a place where groups of students
will fight to have an elevator put in a
several hundred year old building
without me even knowing just because
they feel it is right
it is a place where during spring fling
people will stop to fix my joystick that
dog trampled while strangers will push
me out of dirt
it is also a place where strangers will
run into oncoming traffic when they
notice a water bottle fell from my lap
from a block away
it is a place where professors will make
sure that i am taken care of in their
emergency room while also making sure
that i'm challenged in their classroom
the next day
it is a place where people will form a
circle around me at woads so that i
don't get hit
and it is a place where people will take
on all the rain to hold an umbrella over
me so that my wheelchair doesn't get wet
ultimately
it is a place where things that i viewed
as impossible are made effortlessly
possible
i'll give an example that perhaps marks
my most transformative moment here
i was his first year and a senior at the
time had written a news piece that
though completely well-intentioned made
my experience as a disabled student
looked quite bleak
i ultimately felt that the portrayal
painted a part but not a whole picture
of my experience
so i wrote an article in response to
fill in those missing pieces of light
and joy
i was terrified
it was the best decision that i've made
at yale
all because of the community surrounding
me today
i made one of my best friends she had
lived on my floor but we hadn't really
connected until she reached out to get a
meal after seeing the piece
people who i barely spoke to at the time
re-shared the article on facebook so
many times that it shockingly went to
number one
showing me that people were willing to
listen
still others messaged me every single
day asking if i was okay and reminding
me that it would be okay
people were radically and sincerely open
to making space for difference in
perspective and experience
and i never had to worry about opening a
door again
the experience showed me that what
happened before was actually largely my
fault
i avoided being vulnerable out of fear
and i missed out as a result
this experience is a testament to
vulnerability being supported and even
rewarded here
it is a testament to this community
championing those who create their own
identity
it is a testament to yale being a place
where people who you didn't even know
were your allies will rally behind you
through both moments of tremendous
adversity and victory
it is a testament to this community's
readiness to define yale and the world
by inclusion and betterment
i hope this list of antidotes show that
yale is a place of remarkable passion
for people
for empathy for humility and for doing
the most good in the situations that we
find ourselves in
our community is one marked by an ardent
an ardently selfless commitment to
caring for others
my time here has shown me two things
at yale when we learn from each other
we grow smarter when we lean on each
other
we'd grow stronger
i once read that ray charles's mother
said to him
you might not be able to do things like
a person who can see
but there are always two ways to do
everything
you've just got to find the other way
i wrote in my college application that i
hoped i would achieve that one day
and the yale community has made that
possible by finding that way with me
though the map looks different for
everyone i think that sentiment is at
its core the definition of a yale
experience
so congratulations and perhaps more
importantly thank you to the class of
2022
[Applause]
wow
okay
afternoon everyone i'm victoria winter
i'm chris
[Applause]
i'm christine hoechen
i'm steffi grau and we're members of
your class of 2022 class day committee
[Applause]
and as members of the class day
committee we're up here to help explain
some of the things we've done to help
keep up the yale class day traditions as
we celebrate the graduation of our class
of 2022.
as a member of the 22 class a committee
i coordinated this year's class history
the class history has taken many forms
over the years to tell the story of our
time at yale from live skits to highly
produced scripted movies and nostalgic
slideshows
as an homage to past class histories
while still incorporating student input
this year's video will be a hybrid
between scripted and student submitted
works
after the unveiling of our class history
will be the singing of bright college
years a song written in 1881 by henry
durand which has been the unofficial
alma mater of yale since sung at
reunions football games and class day it
remains a symbol of yale's traditions
and long long history on the last lines
of the song we raise our handkerchiefs
if you lost yours from first years or
never got one like me the yale alumni
association has generously provided new
ones we'll wave them along as years of
graduating classes have done before
singing for god for country and for you
the three incredible student speeches
you've just heard this afternoon by
members of our class are also a
tradition at yale legacies of the days
when yalies delivered formal academic
speeches at the ceremony
each year speakers auditioned before the
class day speaker subcommittee which
this year included myself jayan yusra
who you heard from earlier
the speeches are selected to highlight
the beautiful spectrum of experience
here at yale it was an honor to listen
to so many individual stories all
straight from the heart
we hope you enjoyed the vulnerability
candor emotion and humor that charlotte
chase e high macrena kyle and arya all
brought to the reflections of yale
another tradition is the creation of the
2022 class day anthology which i helped
our class put together and edit as a
member of the class day committee you
can find a copy of it also included in
your class day bags the class day
anthology is a booklet of reflections
works of art and poetry that capture our
beautiful shared yale experience we
selected pieces that we found to be
exceptionally representative of our
times here as students both the happy
experiences as well as the more
challenging ones
we went into this project with the
understanding that there is no such
thing as a singular yale experience we
put together this collection which
encompasses a variety of perspectives
and we hope you'll take the time to read
through it and reflect on your own four
years here or more you might be
surprised at the themes that tie us
together
you'll also find a clay pipe in your
class day gift bag called the church
warden pipe in addition to some bubbles
when this tradition started back in 1869
graduating seniors would sit in a circle
smoking tobacco from these pipes so it's
definitely a different vibe today
we have on these funky hats and we blow
bubbles but this tradition of the church
warden pipe still endures over 150 years
later
another tradition that began in 1851 is
the laying of an ivy plant somewhere on
yale's campus symbolizing the enduring
nature of the frenchies made in the past
four years this year our class ivy will
be placed right inside of phelps gate
planted beneath the stone on the wall
where our year 2022 will be engraved
future generations will come through old
campus and see our ivy and engraved
stone as symbols of the enduring
resilience and strength our class found
here
a lot of time has passed and yale no
longer looks the way it once did the
yellies of today don't look like the
yalies of the 1800s but the planting of
the ivy and the church warden pipe are
two traditions that unite generations of
yale graduates
finally looking ahead to tomorrow
morning's commencement procession as
tradition the recipients of the five
academic prizes that were just awarded
by dean chun will carry an official flag
or banner the winners of the warren
memorial prize russell henry chittenden
prize arthur twining hadley prize
suddler prize and alpheus henry snow
prize carry the american flag
connecticut flag yale college banner
president's banner and yale university
banner respectively these parts of class
day some more silly and some more
serious all link our class of 2022 to
the generations of yale that came before
us as we move from being undergraduates
to alumni of yale university christine
victoria and i along with yusuret and
jay feel so lucky and honored to have
helped our class carry on these
traditions
definitely congratulations everyone
[Music]
before we begin our class history i have
one order of business will the members
of the glee club please make their way
to the bandstand and now without further
ado the 2022 classes
[Music]
dave
i can't believe we're graduating
tomorrow
yeah if only there was a way we could
look back at all of our wonderful times
here
hey why do you guys look so constipated
like in the middle of like
oh we were just trying to remember all
our favorite yale moments well why don't
you just look through the class history
the class what the class history do you
know how we're all assigned personal
librarians when we get into yale
we are yeah and you know over the four
years the personal librarians actually
secretly follow us around and document
our every move and actions and then this
super
sensitive information is compiled into a
book called the class history which
distributed after graduation
no way i don't know how i feel about
that
i feel fine about it so where's the book
oh in the library
oh let's go
hey can we look at the uh
class history
can i get some identification
congrats on the glow up
follow me
[Music]
[Music]
hey look it's a hard video game from
sophomore year
hey look it's the senior showcase from
casey
[Applause]
attention please the library closes in
30 minutes wait what it's only noon wow
these early closing times are getting
really aggressive
get out
hey do you think we could check this out
uh well it's a really valuable archive
and i'm supposed to monitor you whenever
you peruse it
so
yeah why not
[Music]
look at these remember when it used to
snow
[Laughter]
yeah remember when people told us that
it would snow all the time at yale i
guess times really change yeah
hey what's this one
no
hey no one can see this
run
okay
we should be good here yeah
finally we can get rid of this
[Music]
because it's embarrassing of course it's
embarrassing we're college students
college is all about embarrassing
ourselves and the growth we came from we
can't edit our history
i guess you're right class day is for
everyone
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey it's michaela jill murphy aka the
voice of toff beifong from avatar the
last airbender and i just wanted to
reach out and say
congratulations yale class of 2022.
you guys made it you survived you're
part of the real world now whether you
like it or not so enjoy congratulations
you finally made it through and if
you're ever feeling a little overwhelmed
just remember to keep your knees high
twinkle toes
congrats guys
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
for
god for god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right everyone
i've lost my voice from screaming so
much with all of you today but
um we just wanted to say a quick thank
you first of all to the yale faculty and
staff who've made real experiences
possible especially those that are
parting ways with yale with us
those would be people like our heads of
colleges my own head john witt as well
as
[Music]
as well as dean of yale college marvin
chun if you can help me give them all a
round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
last but not least
thank you all very much yo class of 2022
you are free to go stay hydrated and
congratulations class of 22.
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
um
you said
down
my gosh
you